coping with inflation and a currency in
free fall has made life tough people
have sunk into poverty since the economy
began to collapse two years ago the
united nations says nearly 80 percent
are now poor that's three million people
my monthly salary is now worth 70 it's
not enough to buy food for four days the
government has been promising to give us
cash assistance but it never happened
the humanitarian community has stepped
in to provide vital support in a country
made nearly bankrupt by decades of
corruption and mismanagement united
nations statistics tell the story of
growing hardships like 1 million people
in urgent need of aid including food
for the first time ever in the history
of lebanon you have 36 percent of
extreme poverty you know extreme poverty
is not anything it's really something
that never happened never ever happened
in lebanon before
it's not only lebanese who have been
affected by the economic crisis the
living conditions of 850 000 syrians
registered as refugees by the u.n are
rapidly deteriorating
a year ago just over half lived in
extreme poverty now it's nine out of ten
nearly fifty percent don't have enough
food
thirty percent of children have never
gone to school and almost thirty
thousand work
levels of poverty are also high in
palestinian refugee camps and at least
four hundred thousand migrant workers
mainly from asian and african countries
are stranded here without work nor the
means to return home
many parents can't afford to send their
children to school and growing numbers
of people are unable to afford health
care starvation is now a reality for
thousands and malnutrition is increasing
among children
the international community accuses
lebanon's political class of
deliberately failing to act and
defending what members say is a bankrupt
economic system that's why lebanon's
authorities are bypassed when assistance
is provided and they say they'll
continue until state institutions
riddled with corruption are reformed
most of the support that we are going to
provide through
through the erp is also going to be
direct to the population
but many say this help is not a
long-term answer and emergency aid is
not the economic recovery plan lebanon
needs that will depend on its leaders
letting go of a system they have
benefited from for so long
senator al-jazeera beirut